HTML stands for the "hypertext markup language."
Many of you may have some previous experience with HTML,
but that's not necessary.
HTML as w know it was invented to Tim Berners-Lee,
a British computer scientist working in Switzerland around 1990.
For our purposes, HTML just tells a web browser how to display a webpage.
In fact, HTML is not all that different from using symbols like stars or underscores
to emphasis text that you're writing to someone else.
In HTML this emphasized plain text becomes "I,"
and then this special punctuation that means let's do some bold now, "really,"
this special punctuation that means I'm done with bold, let's go back to normal,
and then "like you." The "b" stands for "bold."
Let's go see how that pans out.
Here in this particular window, I'm showing the raw HTML source on the left
and how it might look in a web browser on the right.
Here when I've added the bold tags around really, we see "I really like you."
The "really" is rendered in bold.
Other comment approaches in HTML for emphasis are the use of underlines, the "u,"
and italics, "i." Each one of these is called a "tag."
This special syntax with the "b" in angle brackets and the "b" sort of similar angle brackets,
the "u," the closing "u," the "i," the closing "i,"
is a tag that's associated with that word, or that span of text,
and tells the web browser how to render it.
This part here, the left angle bracket and the right angle bracket--
that's a starting tag, and this other part--the left angle bracket followed by a slash,
the slash is super important, begin an end tag.
That's a little complicated to say.
Mark the start of an ending tag and tell you that the current tag is about to stop.
Here's a beginning bold tag. Here's an ending bold tag.
You can see that play out on the right. Only the word "really" is bolded.